nous sommes sur la côte est américaine
dans l'état du rhode island en route ou
plutôt en mer vers bloc allen qui se
trouve à environ une heure du continent
le vent souffle fort le vent la
principale ressource naturelle de lille
il doit souffler à au moins 10 km heure
pour que les cinq éoliennes y puisent
leur énergie pour approvisionner lille
en électricité les éoliennes en mer sont
deux à trois fois plus puissantes que
les éoliennes en terre elles font partie
du paysage depuis 2007
l'artiste
par wind energy le nord-est du pays est
considéré comme l'arabie saoudite de
l'énergie indienne dix points en seine
au
total les éoliennes produisent 30
mégawatts d'électricité dit il lille
n'en consomme que 4 à 5 à son pic le
reste est exporté au continent ce sont
des câbles sous marins en ce bel issou
le sable qui acheminent d'énergie
d'abord vers lille puis vers le
continent
c'est beaucoup mieux maintenant didou
discret avant l'électricité était très
instable elle fluctue s était terrible
pour les électroménagers il fallait les
remplacer constamment
avant c'était quand l'électricité
provenait de génératrice qui carburait
au diesel les camions-citernes arrivée
sur l'île en traversier pour alimenter
des cinq génératrice qui brûlait à leur
tour 4 millions et demi de litres de
diesel chaque année pour approvisionner
en électricité
c'était bruyant polluants et peu fiable
nous dit jeffrey wright
les éoliennes ont changé la donne dit il
elles ont changé notre
ses génératrices ont servi jusqu'au 1er
mai 2010 est dit il mais on les garde
quand même occasion elles n'ont servi
que 4 à 5 fois depuis quatre ans
mais ces moulins à vent mer ne font pas
l'unanimité
heynckes j'espère qu'elles vont être
frappés par la foudre 12 milliard fcfp
qui vit quête mois par année à bloquer
ce sont des intrus qui gâchent notre
paysage de
la maison appartient la famille depuis
un siècle c'est comme de la mauvaise
herbe dit son mari faut s'en débarrasser
je préférais mettre des panneaux
solaires sur chaque surface plate dit
elle ce programme et ce n'était pas une
option dit la mairesse de l'époque
[Musique]
mais les panneaux solaires font aussi
partie du paysage à block island comme
ici à l'hôtel de ville du tissu souple
aux mairies hyves craint qu'avec l'ajout
des eaux indiennes sont bel horizon se
transforme en une gigantesque
installation industrielle unique archos
life
story
cab local en serre un peu de projets
pilotes pour le reste des états unis
on va passer d'un projet de 100 millions
de dollars à un projet de cent milliards
dit il va y avoir des centaines voire
des milliers d'éoliennes à une trentaine
de kilomètres de la côte pour générer de
l'électricité à des millions de
personnes
oui l'hôtel vois tous ces changements
d'un bon oeil un passionné de voitures
il fait partie de cette génération qui a
grandi dans l'urgence climatique
pour lui la transition énergétique est
inévitable
[Musique]
sa coqueluche c'est sa coccinelle
électrique qu'il a construite à l'âge de
17 ans
c'est en utilisant des piles de vieux
portables que l'adolescent avait bâti
son boulot
j'avais acheté plein d'ordinateur sur
ebay dit il de vieux portable de bureau
je les avait démontés et puis j'ai testé
chaque pile pour en faire une batterie
de voiture
c'est certainement la première voiture
aux états unis d'ici là être rechargée
par l'électricité qui provient et
éolienne en mer
l'impact du réchauffement climatique se
fait beaucoup ressentir ici
il comme beaucoup d'autres fait face à
de l'érosion
chaque année rose mary a espère plus de
2 m de terrain et un peu plus loin la
structure entière du phare de l'île a dû
être déplacé de 91 mètres des falaises
la planète va survivre dit il mais
peut-être pas nous allons nous
l'endommager à tel point qu'on y sera
plus les bienvenus oui
je suis inquiet mais j'ai de l'espoir
dit oued plus gros mais pas c'est sûr
que l'avenir est sombre mais il faut que
les gens se réveillent pour qu'on puisse
songer échoué n'est ce pas
il tente de faire sa part et plusieurs
réfléchissent déjà aux solutions
alternatives en cas de tempête ou les
câbles elysées odienne serait
sérieusement affectée et que deux prix
du diesel deviennent inabordables
[Musique]
la prochaine étape est le stockage
d'énergie dans les batteries dit il
will roll tel n'a pas téléphone
cellulaire mais des projets plein la
tête alain jeunes hillen monstre le
fondateur de tesla et de spacek ce ils
circulent sur l'île sans faire de bruit
mais y'a aucun doute pour lui l'avenir
et dans l'énergie renouvelable
en attendant les éoliennes continue de
tourner pour révolutionner
tranquillement toute la côte est
américaine
[Musique]